[Aplausos]
bom eu fiquei pensando por que que eu
fui escolhida pra aqui hoje com vocês né
já que eu não sou empreendedora não
criei um conceito não sou coaching e nem
solidão de algum negócio né
bom essa luana tenho 30 anos sou
engenheira de materiais
doutor em química cientista formada
nesta universidade que está recebendo o
sedex hoje sou filha de forma inteira o
meu pai walter veio do interior de são
paulo com a sua família e após mandar
vou morrer quando ele tinha 10 anos
a minha avó cuidou dos seus três filhos
sozinha já minha mãe veio lá do sertão
da bahia junto com mais sete irmãos
depois de um tempo que eu vou começar a
trabalhar aqui ele decidiu retornar para
o nordeste ea nova família ficou aqui
cuidando dos seus oito filhos
bom eu cresci inspirada nessas três
marias maria josé maria rosa e rosa
maria minha mãe que me ensinaram que é
preciso ter força e graça e gana sempre
por não ter sido por ter feito só até a
7ª série
a minha mãe dizia que eu poderia
escolher qualquer profissão mas que
deveria estudar muito muito mesmo pois
não queria que fosse jornalista
já meu pai era todo babão sonho melhor
me ver estão pagando odor bom nem
apresentadora do jornal
muito menos garota-propaganda de calça
jeans mas cá estou eu sendo palestrante
de um telex meus pais ensinaram que as
coisas e ouvir os meus objetivos vão ser
alcançados desde que eu tivesse duas
coisas eu e meu irmão se ana dedicação e
paciência dedicação enquanto meu pai
dizia luana não seu melhor a minha mãe
soltava um você não faz mais do que
obrigação
mas foi não fazendo mais do que
obrigação quem descer na universidade
pública
a primeira e única da minha família teve
gente que não acreditou que eu ia
conseguir
falavam pra mim nossa mas ela não tem
cara de engenheira
mas gente aonde já se viu o engenheiro
tem cara onde eu confesso que por um
lado achei que seria difícil mas até que
foi fácil ter sido a primeira da minha
família porque eu tive a liberdade de
viver a universidade da minha forma
coragem foi isso que eu tive para
realizar tudo que eu consegui aqui
dentro
logo no terceiro mês eu comecei a fazer
uma pesquisa científica e um pouco menos
de um ano depois eu recebi esse que foi
o meu primeiro e o primeiro prêmio
acadêmico aqui da universidade
isso me motivou muitos imaginam não é a
gente gosta de fazer um trabalho
apresentar esse trabalho pelas pessoas
já algo muito gratificante você ser
reconhecido por ele
foi indescritível foi assim que eu
abracei tudo o que a universidade
pública me deu
pude e para outro estado realizar um
curso em cursar engenharia de materiais
numa outra universidade federal coisa
que eu nunca imaginei que meu pai não
deixava nem dormir fora de são paulo e
talvez a maior das minhas conquistas que
foi ingressar numa pós-graduação e me
tornar a doutora bom falando tudo isso
você deve estar imaginando a nossa
menina só estudou é uma nerd só vivia
nos livros né
realmente nesses três primeiros anos eu
só fiz isso e eu deixei até a saúde um
pouco de lado
cheguei a correr risco de vida e foi a
partir dessa segunda chance que foi me
dada então resolvi ver a universidade de
uma outra forma
foi assim que comecei a conciliar as
disciplinas da pós-graduação e os
experimentos no laboratório com os
treinos e os jogos de basquete concurso
de os cursos de idiomas com a dança de
salão com o trabalho em ongs inclusive
fui rainha da bateria da universidade
federal do abc da infantaria durante
quatro anos de doutorado é eu imaginei
que se reúnem que é assim ninguém
imagina que uma pessoa está envolvida
consciência
a academia também os professores olhavam
meio torto às vezes né
nossa a gente imagina uma pessoa assim
um pouco mais entendo intelectualizada
introvertida
mas essa foi a identidade que a
universidade me deu aquela era a luana
essa é a aluna foi no meio da maior
oportunidade que eu tive aqui dentro e
talvez até de um sonho realizado que foi
fazer essa pesquisa está de pesquisa lá
no max planck que eu na verdade obtive a
minha maior conquista que foi mostrar
quem nós somos
para os estrangeiros eu sair daqui com o
meu orientador os meus amigos meus pais
do fundo assim luana você abraça todo
mundo você beija todo mundo toma cuidado
os alemães são mais introvertidos vai
chegar lá e já abraçar e beijar todo
mundo né
pois bem eu cheguei na alemanha
no fatídico 7 a 1
é no terceiro dia da alemanha após o
jogo eu recebi o meu primeiro abraço de
uma alemã
eram meus pêsames na verdade dessa
lehman mas eu fiquei extasiada extasiada
eu sair do laboratório pisando em nuvens
só querem chegar no laptop e mandar um e
mail para as pessoas vão mandar uma
mensagem falando eu recebi o abraço de
lã e aí eu entrei elaborada no meu
escritório desde cara com um dos meus
colegas de trabalho alemão ea primeira
coisa que eu fiz foi dar um beijo e um
abraço no alemão
sentei e eu só fui perceber o que
realmente tinha feito quando eu olhei
para o lado e ele estava estático da cor
do estofado de vocês vermelho
eu tinha duas alternativas a primeira
seria ou pedir desculpas só que eu acho
que isso é muito mais constrangedor ou
deixar eu prefiro deixar e foi cometendo
essas pequenas gafes durante todos os
dias que praticamente foi o que eu fiz
foram que as pessoas foram se
acostumando naturalmente como jeito de
ser
até que mesmo depois do aniversário
estava todo mundo me abraçando e
beijando na minha despedida receber um
abraço do meu chefe me agradecer e
desejando boa sorte e naquele momento eu
nunca dei
tanto valor a um abraço cheguei aqui no
brasil superconfiante já estava na época
da minha defesa de tese não é fácil
conseguir os abraços dos alemães não
conseguir tudo agora vai ser tudo mais
fácil
só que as coisas estavam um pouquinho
diferentes em uma pesquisa da naked er
que diz de 2017 que diz que os
estudantes de pós graduação têm seis
vezes mais chances de adquirir
transtornos de ansiedade e depressão
pois bem eu me vi fazendo parte das
estatísticas
quando retornei eu sentia que tinha que
fechar um ciclo
e esse prazo era curto deixei tudo de
lado tudo isso que eu fui pra vocês que
eu fazia e foquei em terminar a minha
tese de doutorado
isso fez com que no dia da minha defesa
eu estivesse em estado de choque
eu não lembro praticamente nada do que
aconteceu nas minhas cinco horas de
jogos são na verdade eu lembro muito
forte daquele dia foi na hora da
comemoração os meus amigos aqui da abc
não é que eu sou da primeira turma então
todo mundo conhecia me dizendo luana
você é demais
luana como você conseguiu você é a minha
inspiração espera em você e aquilo não
fazia nenhum sentido pra mim
com uma semana de reclusão eu saí pela
primeira vez de casa que achava que
estava cansada foi uma moça de
celebração de final de ano e em
determinado momento as pessoas amigo
secreto grita outro pula em cima da mesa
eu comecei a sentir os meus pés
formigarem e as minhas mãos se
contraíram aquela era a minha primeira
crise de ansiedade
depois disso vieram inúmeras eu tenho de
perguntar às pessoas aquilo era normal
professores que tinha muitos professores
que eram muito meus amigos eles estavam
ana foi final de uma fase tudo vai
melhorar
confia e eu fui confiando e tendo crises
até que chegou um determinado momento
foi não eu preciso tocar a minha vida de
novo e eu decidi fazer uma viagem com a
irmã meus primos e vamos para um lugar
muito bonito
no meio dessa viagem a gente vai fazer
uma trilha né
em algum momento eu me distanciei das
pessoas nessa trilha até que eu cheguei
na frente de um precipício
o precipício lindo lindo aquele mar
clarinho
normalmente a gente sente um arrepio é
assim no estômago alguma coisa do gênero
uma vertigem
mas eu só senti vontade de pular lá eu
queria acabar com alguma coisa estava me
incomodando
só que nesse momento a razão acabou
falando um pouquinho mais alto
eu pensei na minha mãe que estava em são
paulo doente teria que talvez vi para
aquela cidade pra resolver alguma coisa
pensei na minha irmã porque eu pulasse a
minha mãe foi indiciada meus primos vão
ser indiciados ou seja e foi aí que eu
decidi que se não fosse por mim seria
por eles que eu ia continuar e eu dei de
cara com com essa paisagem aqui
linda né momentos depois eu pensei 15
minutos depois
se eu tivesse decidido por lá naquele
momento eu não ia presenciar isso mais
não foi fácil durante e depois ainda
nessa oportunidade eu tive crises muitas
crises
eu criei fobias eu tinha fobia de
pessoas
eu tinha fobia divulgar os fechados
fobia de me apresentar em público
o bia de ruídos ruídos ea única coisa
que eu poderia ouvir sem incomodar era o
batuque da bateria
eu comecei a me perder
eu perdi o meu jeito de ser perdi peso
17 quilos perdi a motivação de trabalhar
isso é horrível para quem faz ciência
pesquisa na época a gente tem que fazer
artigos eu não conseguia escrever
só que o problema
o maior foi começar a perder pessoas
comecei a perder as pessoas e foi nesse
momento que eu falei eu preciso pedir
ajuda para alguém porque até então eu
não tinha coragem de contar pra ninguém
meus pais não sabiam os familiares não
sabiam
e aí eu fui uma palestra nesta palestra
houve que a gente precisa ter coragem
lembra aquela coragem que eu falei de
fazer as coisas sim coragem para
levantar e eu fiquei pensando levantar
mas como fazer isso né
como cientista a gente pensa na forma
mais objetiva né
comecei a me levantar e então eu
estabeleci que eu iria me levantar todos
os dias pela manhã junto com o sol
comecei a me levantar para voltar às
atividades físicas
comecei a me levantar para tomar coragem
num barzinho ver os amigos ou em uma
festa de aniversário ou apresentar uma
palestra
eu sabia que precisava continuar
inspirando as pessoas até que eu me
levantei para procurar ajuda médica
perdi o medo então é de tomar medicação
e me levantei pra falar que foi uma das
coisas principais como psiquiatra falou
ana você precisa falar e foi falando que
os meus amigos meus familiares começaram
a tomar conhecimento e me ajudar a
levantar também porque tinha vez que eu
queria desistir
só que eles não desistiram de mim foi me
levantando eu comecei a incentivar
outros amigos a se levantarem que não
tinham coragem de falar também foi me
levantando eu comecei a me encontrar de
novo ea ser eu mesmo a outra vez foi
levantando que eu resolvi aceitar um
novo desafio profissional um grande
desafio e foi me levantando que hoje eu
consegui estar aqui dividindo tudo isso
com vocês
coisas que nem mesmo os familiares
sabiam como acabei de dizer só que agora
é minha vez de perguntar
até quando vocês vão esperar para se
levantar e sair da zona de conforto e
mudar o rumo da vida de vocês
até quando vocês vão esperar para se
levantar e ajudar a pessoa que está do
lado de vocês a se levantar também até
quando vocês vão esperar para se
levantar e fazer daquela dificuldade
aquela dificuldade que cada um tem
guardado que às vezes a gente acha que é
pequenininho mas aqui é muito grande pra
gente e transformar isso em oportunidade
de vencer
vocês vão esperar muito não porque esse
momento é agora
levantem-se sejam corajosos
é nesse momento que se inicia o futuro é
nesse momento que vocês têm a
oportunidade de transformar qualquer
coisa na vida de vocês
ai que lindo é eu acho que agora eu sei
o porquê eu fui escolhida pelo ataque
hoje obrigada gente
[Aplausos]